NO REGRETS:
“It was well worth doing
prison time for The Pirate Bay.” This was the
final battle cry of Pirate Bay cofounder Fredrick
Neij despite getting raided by the police multiple
times, being fined 46 million kroner, and being
thrown in prison alongside some of the most vile
people on Earth. In fact, Fredrick was the only
person in his entire prison that was there for a
virtual crime. Everyone else there was convicted
of robbery, assault, manslaughter, or worse. But,
things were not too bad in prison says Fredrick.
He immersed himself with reading letters from
fans about how much the Pirate Bay meant to them.
This isn’t to say that Fredrick willing turned
himself in though. Like any normal human being,
he very much dreaded the idea of going to
jail and he was on the run for several years
as one of the most hated individuals by media
organizations around the world. But, eventually,
the law did catch up with him putting him behind
bars. But, this only strengthened Fredrick’s
personal conviction as the letters reminded him
of why did everything in the first place. Unlike
other piracy website creators, Fredrick wasn’t
trying to make money or get rich or screw over
big companies. He had founded The Pirate Bay out
of principle. The idea that information, culture,
and knowledge should be shared freely around the
world without the interference of corporate greed,
bureaucracy, or political influence. In fact,
Fredrick had been fighting for this cause long
before he co founded the Pirate Bay or gained any
sort of notoriety. Before his Pirate Bay days,
Fredrick was part of a Swedish anti copyright
group that went around the world engaging in
piracy debates and giving lectures about
the right to information. This is where
Fredrick met the other founders Gottfrid
Svartholm and Peter Sunde. And together,
they would go on to create one of the most
controversial yet legendary sites of all time. So,
here’s how the Pirate Bay went from being an
ideological effort to becoming an international
icon despite police raids, jail time, and
the efforts of the media industry at large.
THE SCALLYWAGS:
The story of the Pirate Bay dates back
to the late 1970s and early 1980s to the country
of Sweden where all three of our protagonists
were born. Not much is known about any of the
founders’ childhoods, but from what we do know,
it wasn’t anything to brag about. Fredrick was the
oldest of the bunch having been born on April 27,
1978 in the city of Jönköping Sweden. There’s
rumors that he dropped out of high school and
it appears that he just stumbled though his life
one day at at time. A similar story could be said
about Gottfrid as well who was the youngest
of the bunch having been born on October 17,
1984. Gottfrid was your classic computer
nerd/hacker of the 1990s and 2000s. Think
Dennis Nedry from Jurassic Park. And then
there was Peter Sunde who was the only one
that would be considered somewhat successful
by modern society, but this wasn’t to say the
his childhood was any better. Peter was born on
September 13, 1978 in Uddevalla Sweden. At first,
he life wasn’t all that bad. His mother was
a staff consultant at a large company and
his father was a traveling mechanic. But, all of
this fell apart when Peter’s parents got a divorce
when he was just 8 years old. His mother would
become clinically delusional as she developed
psychosis which resulted in the family constantly
moving all across Scandanavia. Unsurprisingly,
Peter would end up dropping out of school in
his teens, but there was one saving grace:
computers. Computers were Peter’s one and only
escape from his harsh realty and this led to him
becoming quite a skilled programmer. Ironically,
if he had this same childhood in modern times,
it’s likely that he would’ve become a lifeless
social media addict like myse..Anyways,
things were different back then. The people
spending all of their time on computers weren’t
endlessly scrolling through TikTok. They were
enthusiasts learning how to code and hack systems,
and this would catch the attention of German
technology company Siemens. Siemens is the people
behind many of the IT systems used at hospitals,
and they would hire Peter to upgrade their patient
registration system from being fingerprint based
to being retinal based. It seemed like a pretty
good gig at first glance, but Peter could not
stand it at Siemens after he joined. He would
discover that his development efforts were being
used to identify and deport illegal immigrants
leading them to do unthinkable things. You see,
many of these immigrants would burn their fingers
on kitchen stoves before visiting the hospital to
avoid being identified. This was actually one of
the main reasons that Siemens wanted to switch
to a retinal system. But this simply gave Peter
nightmares about immigrants poking out their
eyes like Victor Creel. He tried to take it
up with his managers, but this simply gave him
the title of being negative and difficult to
work with. Being drained from work everyday,
the only solace Peter found was during the
evenings when he scrolled through online forums
leading him to discover the world of piracy.
FOUNDING THE PIRATE BAY:
Peter’s piracy journey started
with him swapping music and movies on invite only
servers which led him to meeting fellow scallywag:
Fredrick Neij. Fredrick introduced Peter to the
file-sharing movement and to the newly founded
anti copyright organization: Piratbyrån or The
Pirate Bureau. Piratbyrån was founded on August 1,
2003 by a bunch of societal outcasts just like
Peter, Fredrick, and Gottfrid. Their goal was
to make information available to people of all
backgrounds and stature, and promote free speech
above everythign else. Not saying I agree with
how they went about doing this, but honestly,
it does seem like their intentions were way more
pure than most of the people who actually control
the world today. With this idea in mind, the
group got to work. Some members tried opposing
pro copyright lobbyist groups. Others traveled the
world and gave lectures on radio and TV. Our trio
decided to create a website. This was specifically
Fredrick’s idea. He wanted to create a Bittorrent
tracker and he would recruit the help of Peter
and Gottfrid for the IT and coding side of things.
Given the relative simplicity of the website,
Peter and Gottfrid had this up and running in
no time and Piratbyrån would launch the website on
September 15, 2003. This was actually just one of
many websites that this trio launched. Moving into
2004, Fredrick and Gottfrid would create a full
on internet service provider and web hosting
company called PRQ. Don’t be fooled though,
this was no AT&T. With PRQ, Fredrick and Gottfrid
looked to give an online voice to anyone and
everyone regardless of what they stood for or did.
This included some unheard and repressed voices
but it also included a bunch of creeps literally.
There were a bunch of forums hosted on PRQ that
advocated for how should I say it: unorthodox
relationships. Though Fredrick and Gottfrid
definitely did not agree with everything that
was hosted on their platform, they defended all
of their customers equally citing freedom speech.
Something else that sparked a bunch of controversy
was yet another one this duo’s ventures: Americas
Dumbest Soldiers. Honestly, this one was quite
distasteful. The website consisted of a list of
deceased American soldiers and it prompted people
to vote on how dumb their deaths were. Little
to say, this site didn’t stay up for very long.
While these other ventures definitely caused
a scene by themselves, it turned out that the
trio’s original venture would have the greatest
sticking power. And luckily for them, it was
pretty cheap to run. Afterall, the Pirate Bay
didn’t actually have any file hosting or server
to client downloading abilites built in. The site
simply connected people with a library of links
and all of the downloading took place using peer
to peer protocols. So, the trio just had to ensure
that they had enough server capacity to handle
all of the search volume, indexing, sorting, and
filtering itself. But, to their surprise it didn’t
take long for this itself to become unmanageable.
THE LEGENDARY RISE:
As the Pirate Bay exploded it popularity,
it became abundantly clear that this could
no longer be treated as a side project. So,
in October of 2004, the trio would transition the
site into being a standalone non profit based in
the Seychelles, though this is disputed.
If you also have no idea what this place,
you’re not alone. The Seychelles is an East
African country that’s composed of a 115
islands and it just so happened to be the perfect
place to setup a shell company. Now, they had an
entity. All they needed was infrastructure. Enter
Carl Lundström. This guy was one of five heirs to
the Wasabrod fortune. I’ve actually never heard
of this company, but they’re super big. They’re
extremely popular across Scandinavia and they’re
actually the largest crisp bread producer in the
world. By the time Carl turned 22, this company
would be sold to a Swiss pharmaceutical company
called Sandoz which made Carl a mega millionaire
by the time most of us would even graduate
college. Carl would turnaround and use this wealth
to fund a variety of extreme political movements
and it wasn’t long till he crossed paths with
our protagonists. He would agree to provide the
Pirate Bay with all of the required servers and
infrastructure and before you knew it, the Pirate
Bay would become a fully funded venture making
copyright holders around the world cry. But,
they weren’t crying for long. They were hurt
and they were hurt bad. Hollywood claims that
in 2006 alone, piracy cost them $6.1 billion.
And the biggest culprit enabling this asinine
behavior was the Swedish site that was just one
Google search away: the Pirate Bay. Naturally,
Hollywood wanted revenge, they wanted justice.
So, they marched over to the Swedish authorities
and demanded that the Pirate Bay be taken down as
soon as possible. This was met with a chuckle from
Sweden. I’m not even kidding. You see, Sweden is
surprisingly chill about copyright and patents. In
fact, they have a full on political party called
the Pirate Party who’s entire focus is to reform
copyright law. Hollywood was gobsmacked and they
would take their grievances to the good old USA.
Surely, their hundreds of millions of lobbying
dollars would actually earn them some respect from
the American authorities and they were right.
The US would turn around and go “Yo Sweden,
you better shutdown those mischievous rascals
you got there. You don’t want us to bring out
the stick and impose trade sanctions through the
World Trade Organizations right?” And to that
Sweden would respond “Your wish is our command”
and they would go ahead and raid the Pirate Bay’s
servers in Stockholm on May 31, 2006. There was
so much equipment that the Swedish police would
end up filling three trucks worth of computer
equipment and servers. Surely, this would put
an end to the nonsense they thought. Ummm, the
Pirate Bay would be back up in just 3 days.
HOLLYWOOD STRIKES BACK:
You’re probably wondering, how was the trio
able to restart the Pirate Bay so quickly? Well,
the answer is that the Pirate Bay is nothing. It’s
really just a massive excel sheet with a bunch of
links. In fact, the entirety of the Pirate Bay can
be compressed into a 90 megabyte zip file. So,
they didn’t have to maintain massive convoluted
code bases and repositories or enterprise
resource planning software. All of the servers
and equipment were simply there to support the
extraordinary traffic. So, as soon as they were
able to find new infrastructure, they were able
to upload their tiny little zip file and go live
in no time. This time, they chose to put their
servers in a more discrete location somewhere in
the Netherlands so that the police couldn’t just
turn around and raid them again. Hollywood was
triggered. Not only was the Pirate Bay back up and
running, but the police raid had simply drawn even
more attention to the website. Clearly, Hollywood
didn’t have much power in Sweden, so they turned
their focus to American companies. They might
not be able to shutdown the Pirate Bay, but maybe
they could prevent you from accessing it. They
started working with Google, Facebook, Microsoft,
and ISPs to suppress the sharing and searching
of Pirate Bay links, but this only made things
worse. Here’s the thing, when you tell people
not to do something, that’s when they want to do
it even more and this couldn’t be any truer with
the Pirate Bay. Just because Facebook or Google
suppressed Pirate Bay links doesn’t mean jack. You
don’t have to be a rocket scientist to go directly
to the Pirate Bay and search up whatever you want,
and that was exactly what was happening. By 2008,
the Pirate Bay became the 97th most visited
website on the entire internet, and they were
even having talks about selling the website to
Global Gaming Factory X AB for $8.5 million. It
was becoming abundantly clear that there was only
one way to stop this madness: strike the tent.
On January 31, 2008, Swedish prosecutors would
file charges against Gottfrid, Fredrick, Peter,
and Carl. From the very beginning, this was an
open and shut case. The Pirate Bay’s lawyers tried
to defend that the Pirate Bay was simply hosting
links, and that it wasn’t actually encouraging or
enabling piracy. If you want, you could use the
site to share opensource software. While this was
technically true, I mean, let’s face it, these
guys were literally part of Piratbyrån and all
of this was completely intentional. So, their
argument was quickly shut down and on April 17,
2009, all four of them would be sentenced to
one year in jail along with a 30 million kroner
fine which is about $3.5 million. They would try
appealing and this did result in shorter prison
sentences. Fredrick would be down to 10 months,
Peter would be down to 8 months, and Carl would be
down to 4 months. But, the appeal also came with a
larger fine of 46 million Kroner or $6.5 million.
The walls were closing in, and there was only
one thing that the trio could do: get on the run.
UNSTOPPABLE LEGACY:
If you’re wanted by Hollywood
at large for causing billions of dollars worth of
lost revenue, you would think that it would be a
good to lay low. But all three of our protagonists
would do the exact opposite. Fredrick would run
away to Laos/Thailand and he would create yet
another file sharing site called BayFiles in
2011. Apparently, this website was supposed to
comply with copyright rules, but you can take that
for what you will. Not only did Fredrick launch
another site, but he would regularly cross the
border between Laos and Thailand because he had
residences in both countries. In fact, he crossed
the border almost 30 times before getting caught
in November of 2014 at which point he would be
deported back to Sweden where he spent 200 days
in jail. Atleast Fredrick created another side
that was legal atleast on the front. Gottfrid on
the other hand would run away to Cambodia and go
full on spy mode and became a regular hacker for
Wikileaks. He would literally infiltrate Denmark’s
social security and driver’s license databases. I
don’t think that you’d be surprised to hear that
when he was caught in August of 2012, his prison
sentence would be upped to three and a half years,
but he would be let go after 3 years. And
finally as for Peter, well, my man straight up
joined Finland’s Pirate party and ran for European
Parliament in the 2014 election. Let’s just say,
he was arrested a few days after the election and
had to serve five months in jail. By late 2014,
all three founders were not only disconnected
from the Pirate Bay, but they were all straight
up in jail. So, prosecuters figured that this was
the perfect time to end this once and for all. On
December 9, 2014, the police would conduct yet
another raid on the Pirate Bay and they would
shut down the original website once and for all.
Surely, the founders couldn’t pull any quick ones
this time right? Well, they were right. None
of the founders would try to restart the Pirate
Bay after their jail sentence. Fredrick would
return Laos and get a job in IT. Peter would
work on a micropayments system called Flattr and
a messaging platform called Hemlis. Gottfrid would
also return to the IT sector and move on from
the Pirate Bay, but none of this mattered. Yes,
the founders were done and out, but there were
thousands of people wanting to carry on the
legacy. Remember how we talked about it being
really easy to store the entirety of the Pirate
Bay. Well, it turns out that a lot of people had
been regularly saving copies of the website. So
whenever one version of the website is taken
down, it’s just a matter of time until another
one pops up with a slightly different domain.
At first, prosecutors tried taking down these
websites one after another, but it quickly became
evident that this was simply a waste of time,
effort, and resources because the legacy
of the Pirate Bay was truly unstoppable.
THE FINAL SAY:
In the end, the Pirate
Bay started off as a project created by a bunch of
misfits and outcasts, but it quickly turned into
the icon of the internet and the worst nightmare
of copyright holders. Hollywood tried burying it,
shredding it, and burning it, but in the end
they decided to just give it all away because
what other choice did they really have. Also,
if you’re wondering about what happened to the
fine well here’s what Peter had to say about it.
During the press conference following the verdict,
Peter would hold up a sign saying that he owes
the government 31 million kroner and that that
confession is all that the government
would get. If that wasn’t clear enough,
he would go onto clarify that he doesn’t have the
money he didn’t have any money and even if he did,
he’d rather burn everything and not even give them
the ashes. And that right there is the legendary
history of the Pirate Bay. Do you guys think
piracy is moral? Comment that down below. Also,
drop a like if you’ve ever downloaded something
that you maybe shouldn’t have. And of course,
consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered.